hey Vsauce Michael here and today we're
going to talk about this what's
happening right now the English language
a language spoken by more than a billion
people with many many different accents
and according to last year's Harvard
Google study a language with more than a
million words growing at a rate of 8,500
new words every single year but we're
getting ahead of ourselves
where did English begin well for that
answer we're gonna have to go all the
way back to the Year 400 and even
earlier to this little Germanic
Peninsula jutting off at an angle
inhabited by people who appropriately
were called angles now these angles
began immigrating to an island named
Britain in fact there were so many
angles there you may as well have called
it angle land angle and England before
they had Latin characters they wrote
their language not in letters but in
what are known as runes and everything
was fine and dandy until 1066 when the
Normans invaded and won one of the
neatest changes that still affects us
today is the fact that this new norman
ruling class would refer to the meet
they were served using their own words
like beef or pork but the poor old
anglo-saxons who had to tend to the
animals still used their early old
english words for instance cow and pig
and to this day that is why English is
one of the very few languages on earth
that has a different name for the meat
of an animal than the name of the animal
it came from English did this a lot
borrow words from other languages and
other people and just plop it right down
into the English vocabulary so see
English is really fun or should I say
fun is really English that's right
unlike all of these borrowed words the
word fun can be traced all the way back
to the angles
and the proto-germanic word Fano which
referred to a piece of cloth or a rag it
eventually came to mean a piece of
fabric say a hoisted flag that flew in
the breeze and then it came to just mean
anything that was high flying or buoyant
you know like fun stuff singling out
which words in English were borrowed and
which ones were originally Germanic can
be a pretty fun exercise for instance
supervised is derived from Latin but
over si that's straight-up Germanic well
what would sound like if we just got rid
of all these words that didn't
originally come from the angles well
what you would have is what is known as
English English is really fun to read
because it's not really a real language
it's just an exercise that we can do
nowadays my favorite is this passage
explaining atomic theory of course you
can't call it atomic theory because for
instance the word atom is Greek meaning
something that cannot be divided any
further so instead of using the word
atom writers will use words like unclear
e they'll use a word like beholding
there's a link in the description to
read all of unclipped beholding but now
let's talk about accents we don't all
speak English the same way and as a
confession I'm gonna say I'm terrible at
impressions accents dialects I pretty
much only ever talk like this
luckily I read the science and young
children are the best at picking up new
accents so I brought along my friend
Todd nicely done
thank you it's a classic vsauce move now
Todd is from barely political in the key
of awesome and he is fantastic at
accents Oh grazie Mike
I'm impressed every day but here's a
challenge for you are you ready
ciao Don I want you to do an impression
of exactly how you think George
Washington spoke let me just picture him
I've seen him on the quarter before I
think he probably sounded like this
what's up playa uh y'all gonna vote for
me I'm gonna take two terms just give me
one one shot and I'm a one-and-done baby
you know I'll say nah Cicely father I do
not chop down at your tree
I like that but you know what there's no
way to be wrong well I mean there are
ways to be wrong but we don't know the
real answer because back at the time
that America first became a country the
classic British accent didn't even exist
yet in fact quite like the Queen's
English yeah that would be completely
foreign to them but here's what's really
mind-blowing about what the British gave
to America Southern drawl
that's right these people known as the
Cavaliers came over to America before it
was an actual independent country and
they brought things like the word y'all
snickerdoodle varmint and they brought
the word axed instead of ask and the
word ain't as well as emphasizing the
first syllable of words like guitar July
and police man I've taken a lot of heat
from English people for being from Texas
and all that and they started it didn't
they
but listen to this the bow language was
a language spoken on an island off the
coast of India and then last year this
woman died she was the final speaker of
the language all I can think about is
that lady trying to connect to people
like oh let us share in the cultural
joke you know the famous cultural joke
of the bow people yes yes it was
probably quite lonely Tod modern English
as we know it didn't really begin that
long ago think of it this way there's a
time capsule buried here in New York
that is not gonna be opened until the
years 6939 by then English itself may be
completely different or possibly extinct
and so they actually included a drawing
of the human mouth where they diagrammed
out where you need to put your tongue to
say the letters like we say them today
and we only have to wait almost 5,000
years what a bargain how convenient for
everyone yeah what are we gonna do in
the meantime well you can head over to
my channel for some comedy stuff we did
an episode of Vsauce called Vsauce
unplugged there's a lot of neat
information over there about the brain
and language some joking around and I
got to talk to Dale do ya sale the mouse
he does not play around no be sure to
check out the cheese shorts video over
at odds channel it's much more funny
than Vsauce but when you're there and
every time I'm there I'm just impressed
by the characters and the accents we got
all sorts stuff we got behind the scenes
key of awesome stuff we got stand up
meeting Stan got me going to China we
got all sorts of comedy stuff come over
for a visit done give you bonus ooh yeah
come on I'll see you there and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
Oh